did you know that two out of every three
guys are going to experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35
i definitely know for me i was around 25
when i started to lose all of my hair i
wish keeps a bit around when i was
younger because advancements in science
meant that there are now treatments that
can combat the symptoms of hair loss and
help you keep the hair that you have
look it's too late for me my hair's not
coming back but you don't have to be
like me you can stop your hair loss
early thanks to keeps keeps off as
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved drugs for treating hair
loss so you may have tried them before
but never at a price this low that's
right if you were thinking oh boy this
is some sort of medicine it's about to
get extremely expensive well you
couldn't be more wrong because keep
starts are just dollars a month how does
it work well for one thing there's no
need to visit a doctor's office just
schedule a quick online consult and a
bit later discreet package is going to
arrive at your door and you can use it
in the privacy of your own home so if
you're noticing that you're losing your
hair that's one problem that's not gonna
fix itself do something about it so for
a limited time you go to keeps.com
forward slash biographics or click the
link in the description below and you'll
get 50 off your first order and now
today's video
in the 18th century much of the world
was still unknown to european
civilization as shipbuilding and
navigation technology improved trade
routes expanded from the great cities of
europe across the globe countries played
a game of empire building setting out to
find new lands to claim for themselves
gambling that as yet undiscovered
islands and even entire continents would
hold vast riches for them to exploit to
accomplish this they needed explorers
daring ship captains that had no qualms
about being tens of thousands of miles
from home alone in a vast ocean who
could navigate the unknowns and return
to port to tell their discoveries
perhaps the best known of these
explorers was captain james cook who
embarked on three different expeditions
that spanned 12 years filling in much of
the map of the pacific ocean with his
discoveries his adventures read like a
robert louis stevenson novel complete
with surviving vicious storms and near
shipwrecks battling tribes of hostile
natives setting foot in places no
european had ever been before and
returning home to become an
international hero cook's one major flaw
was that he let his fame go to his head
he truly began to believe his own hype
and it eventually led to his spectacular
and sudden downfall that is just as
famous as his globe spanning adventures
[Music]
james cook was born on the 7th of
november 1728 in a small village in
yorkshire england his father also named
james was a farmer having risen to the
lofty position of foreman at the largest
estate in the region his son might have
been expected to follow in his father's
footsteps and thus would have
disappeared into history but that was
not his destiny as it quickly became
clear that young james was not suited
for farm work in 1746 after leaving an
apprenticeship at a grocery store the
young james traveled to whitby a
prominent port city where he was
introduced to the owner of a merchant
fleet taken on as a siemens apprentice
it appeared that he had found his life's
calling cook took to sailing with gusto
not only learning the technical side of
the trade but also the academic teaching
himself the advanced mathematics and
astronomy needed for navigation this
allowed him to quickly rise through the
ranks of the merchant marines until by
1755 his employers were ready to offer
him the captaincy of one of their ships
cook would have been set for life
earning a comfortable living in a
respected profession in society but that
wonderlust that would follow cook all
his life to seek out new horizons hit
him again and to the astonishment of
everyone who knew him he rejected the
promotion and instead decided to join
the royal navy as an able seaman cook
must have made an odd sight among his
shipmates aboard the hms eagle when he
came aboard and when they discovered
he'd given up a career in the merchant
navy to become one of them they probably
thought he was just a bit insane royal
navy sailors were jealous of their
merchant counterparts they were
generally better paid lived in less
cramped and feted quarters spent more
time at home and usually weren't subject
to the overbearingly harsh discipline
commonly imposed by military officers of
the period in addition royal navy
officers were almost always the
well-to-do sons of the landed gentry who
had been serving aboard warships since
before they'd gone through puberty james
cook with his humble background and late
start seemed to stand little chance of
ever commanding a ship it just didn't
seem possible in the rigid class
structure of 18th century britain
nonetheless cook superiors quickly took
notice of his intelligence and
experience and plucked him out of the
depths of the ship and within two years
he'd been promoted to sailing master
responsible for navigating the ship a
very important role and likely as high
as he would ever be able to rise within
the royal navy cook saw action during
the seven years war against france and
played a key role in the siege of quebec
when he surveyed and mapped the entrance
of the saint lawrence river allowing
british general wolf to launch his
famous surprise assault that captured
the city recognized for his navigational
and cartographic skill cook was
commissioned to chart the coast of
newfoundland which consumed most of his
time over the course of the next five
years his maps of the island were so
thorough that they were still being used
by sailors 200 years after he made them
[Music]
once he completed his survey of
newfoundland cook returned to britain
and his wife elizabeth who had married
in 1762. despite the long years he spent
away from her it was apparent that he
loved his wife deeply and flaunted the
traditional notion of a sailor having a
girl in every port by never being
unfaithful to her in 1768 though it
seemed like james is going to have a lot
of time to spend with elizabeth in their
london home because his naval career
appeared to have stalled not currently a
war the royal navy was being drawn down
and there were few positions available
even for a talented man like cook it was
at this point that fortune smiled on
cook through a remarkable set of
circumstances the royal society was
britain's scientific authority and they
were excited by an upcoming astronomical
event that promised great potential for
scientific advancement on the 3rd of
june 1769 the planet venus would cross
the face of the sun in the earth's sky
by accurately charting the precise time
that the transit of venus began and
ended from different points around the
earth it was believed that it would be
possible to precisely calculate the
earth's distance from the sun what is
today known as an astronomical unit au
one of the points it was decided to
observe the transit of venus from was
the newly discovered pacific island of
tahiti and the royal society proposed a
voyage there a young scientist named
joseph banks was deeply interested in
the voyage for reasons that had nothing
to do with astronomy banks was a
botanist largely self-taught because of
a teenage fascination with plants that
had parlayed into a career it had
certainly helped that he had a sizable
inheritance to fall back on though banks
figured that if he led the expedition to
tahiti he'd discover hundreds if not
thousands of new plants and animal
species and become a household name he
went to one of his influential friends
the earl of sandwich for help in
sponsoring the voyage sandwich was
interested in the idea for his own
reasons it had been a long-held dream of
his for a british ship to be the first
to discover the fabled southern
continent that was supposed to be
situated on the bottom of the world to
counterbalance the land in the northern
hemisphere scientists had convinced
themselves that antarctica was a
boundless land of plenty chock full of
natural resources to enrich whoever
broke through the treacherous southern
ocean to find it first there was no
reason he thought that a single voyage
could not fulfill everyone's purposes at
once but there was a problem the royal
society believing the voyage to be
primarily scientific in nature wanted
one of their own to command the
expedition banks himself coveted the
posting the royal navy balked at the
idea insisting that any ship sent to the
pacific would be commanded by a naval
officer banks hit on what he thought
would be a compromise he would advocate
for a senior non-commissioned officer to
command the voyage one that had the
requisite navigational and cartographic
experience but lacked the social
standing that banks did so banks could
effectively tell him what to do without
being formally in command a friend of
sandwiches had just the man in mind
james cook
and so it was that cook out of nowhere
was promoted to first lieutenant and
given command of the expedition aboard
the hms endeavour the ship left port in
august 1768 making a stop in brazil
before making the treacherous trip
around the tip of south america cape
horn now in the pacific endeavour headed
north to tahiti along the way he endured
a private battle of wills with banks who
tried to enact his plan to take command
of the expedition banks was sent
undercut by frequent bouts of
seasickness it being difficult to issue
commands when you are constantly
throwing up and any credibility he had
left was destroyed when a shore
expedition he led went wrong and two of
the men froze to death no one would ever
question cook's command again endeavour
arrived in tahiti in april 1769 and
spent weeks there preparing to observe
the transit of venus it was here that
james cook encountered the native
polynesians for the first time he
adopted a paternalistic view of them
believing them to be noble but simple
savages that needed to be guided by men
of reason such as himself cook would
eventually believe himself to be an
expert in the native tribes of the
pacific making attempts to learn their
language and customs but his incomplete
knowledge and dismissive attitude
towards them would come back to haunt
him one day after observing the transit
endeavour headed southwest looking for
antarctica they didn't find it of course
and after a while cook turned west
intending to sail around the previously
unexplored new zealand it was cook who
discovered that new zealand is actually
made up of two different islands with
what is now known as cook strait
separating them endeavour sailed around
both islands cooked charting and naming
places as he went along before heading
west and doing the same thing to the
eastern coastline of australia then
known as new holland nearly being
shipwrecked in the process after the
ship ran around on the great barrier
reef after surviving that endeavour
sailed for home arriving in july 1771.
the voyage was considered a sensational
success banks had collected over 30 000
specimens of plants during the voyage
leading to the discovery of 1 300 new
species a 25 increase in the amount of
known flora at the time cooked
circumnavigated the globe and charted
places never seen before by europeans
and in the process had not lost a single
man to scurvy the dreaded scourge of
18th century sailing that would later be
traced to severe vitamin c deficiency
cook found that feeding a sailor's fresh
food whenever possible and in particular
citrus fruits and sauerkraut kept his
sailors healthy though it would take
decades for the royal navy to start
implementing this in the rest of their
fleet but cook still hadn't found
antarctica and to make matters worse
banks had used a sustained publicity
campaign to make himself out as the hero
of the expedition reducing cook to a
mere footnote so after a year ashore in
england cook was ready to try again
discovering and claiming the proposed
great southern continent was a growing
obsession for king george iii in the
early part of the 1770s so in 1772 the
royal navy promoted cook and gave him a
new mission bind antarctica however long
it took for this voyage cook was to be
in command of two ships hms resolution
and hms adventure initially joseph banks
was to accompany cook on this second
trip to the pacific but after banks's
proposed modifications to the resolution
for his own comfort proved liable to
capsize the ship in heavy seas they were
scrapped banks threw a fit and refused
to go probably thinking the admiralty
would cave to his demands and was
therefore very surprised when they
simply found other scientists to go in
his stead cook's expedition got underway
in july 1772 heading down the coast of
africa to cape town to resupply before
the two ships made their first attempt
to head south becoming the first vessels
known to have crossed the antarctic
circle they began to encounter sea ice
the farther south they went and cook
eventually turned back because he feared
the ice water would either smash his
ship to pieces or freeze them in place
leaving his men to starve or freeze to
death this was another unexpected
scientific discovery until now it was
thought that it wasn't possible for
saltwater to freeze cook headed for the
pacific running into problems with the
captain of the adventure tobias furno
cook was incensed to discover that men
aboard the adventure were getting sick
and dying of scurvy because furno was
not following the dietary regimen that
cooked prescribed burnout probably
wasn't the best choice to serve as
cook's lieutenant on this voyage
eventually the two vessels were
separated from each other inferno lost
his nerve after some of his men were
killed and eaten by maori cannibals in
new zealand he sailed for home
abandoning the mission cook meanwhile
seemed determined to see every inch of
the pacific for himself he sailed in a
wide meandering circle that took him
across polynesia and melanesia and he
made another attempt to find antarctica
reaching 71 degrees south latitude
before finding his path completely
blocked by sea ice a record that stood
for decades he made one more attempt in
the south atlantic discovering south
georgia and the south sandwich islands
but no antarctica cook concluded that if
the great southern continent existed at
all it was entirely contained in the
deep southern latitudes that were
covered year-round in ice even if they
were discovered they wouldn't be worth
anything with that question answered he
sailed for home arriving in july 1775.
this time around cook didn't have to
share the spotlight with anybody he was
great britain's foremost adventurer a
celebrity known all over the western
world he had done something nobody had
done before circa navigated the globe at
extreme southerly latitudes braving
terrifying storms and hostile natives in
the process cook enjoyed his newfound
fame doing the 18th century equivalent
of the talk show circuit by accepting
invitations to dinners at wealthy
mansions and regaling his hosts with his
adventures the royal navy promoted him
to post-captain and at his request put
him out to pasture placing him in charge
of the royal navy hospital in greenwich
which served as a retirement home for
sailors cook himself seemed destined for
retirement
[Music]
in 1776 king george and his government
had more pressing concerns than
antarctica war was the american colonies
threatened to disrupt the transatlantic
trade which was the lifeblood of the
british empire for the earl of sandwich
now first lord of the admiralty it was
more important than ever to cultivate
new trade links wherever they could the
biggest prize was the so-called
northwest passage route around the north
american continent from the atlantic to
the pacific ocean this route would save
thousands of miles on a sea trip from
europe to asia and would avoid the
hazardous trips around the southern tips
of south america and africa there was
only one problem while everyone was
convinced that a northwest passage
existed no one had ever actually found
it the passage was so important to the
king that he offered a staggering prize
of twenty thousand pounds worth almost
fifty million dollars in today's money
to the first man who found it the
fortune on offer proved too tempting for
cook to resist and he volunteered
himself to sandwich to lead the
expedition sandwich was only too happy
to have lured his old friend now the
world's most famous explorer out of
retirement hms resolution would again
serve as cook's flagship for the voyage
with a second ship hms discovery
replacing the adventure cook departed
from great britain in july 1776. no one
knew it at the time but the sea captain
would never see his homeland or his
family again
the official purpose of cook's voyage
was to return amay a polynesian man who
had been taken to europe during cook's
last journey back to his home in tahiti
once this was done cook could turn his
attention to his actual objective the
northwest passage in december 1777 cook
left tahiti and headed north making for
the california coastline it was during
this trip that he first came across the
island in the middle of the pacific that
no european had ever seen before he had
discovered the northernmost hawaiian
islands cook spent most of the rest of
1778 trying to find the northwest
passage sailing through the bering
strait and charting the coastline of
alaska in the process eventually he
found his path blocked by ice and turned
back cook wanted to make another attempt
the next year hoping that making the
attempt in summer would provide a route
through the ice but first he needed a
place to spend the winter so he headed
back to hawaii in november they sighted
the island of maui and soon after the
big island of hawaii after exploring
these new lands for two months
resolution and discovery dropped anchor
on the southwestern coast of hawaii by
pure chance cook's arrival coincided
with the native hawaiian harvest
festival celebrating lono the god of the
harvest there is some speculation that
the hawaiians thought cook was the
personification of lono there to visit
them which would explain the initial
excitement surrounding his visit before
long however relations between cook's
crew and the natives had deteriorated
significantly and both sides were happy
to see the two ships depart from the bay
after a month to return to the beiring
sea however soon after leaving they were
caught in a storm and the foremast on
the resolution broke off and cook
returned to the bay for repairs for the
hawaiians this was an unexpected and
unwelcome surprise and it set off a
chain of events that would end in
violence
on all three of his trips cook had to
deal with native polynesians and
malanesians stealing things from his
crew he did not understand that the
natives had a very different definition
of property than the europeans and felt
that since cook's ships had so much
extra stuff with them they shouldn't
mind sharing it with the people who
didn't have it over time cook began to
retaliate against the natives in even
more harsh ways from kidnapping tribal
elders to ransom them back for the
stolen items to flogging the offenders
with a bullwhip on this particular trip
however cooker descended into outright
barbarism in an attempt to deter
thievery by the natives during a
three-month stay in tonga cook adored
dozens of natives lashed and when that
didn't work he started cutting off ears
shooting natives and then forcing them
to try and swim to shore beating them
with boat ors and other blunt objects
and in at least one case he had a cross
cut into a man's arm going all the way
down to the bone many of cook's crew
were veterans of his previous voyage and
was shocked by his marked change in
demeanor from previous trips not only
was he less patient and more savage than
native populations they came across but
the usually careful man was making
mistakes in judgment and spent more and
more time sequestered in his cabin cook
was probably ill for great stretches of
the voyage complaining in his journal of
a stomach ailment among other things but
at least part of it was his oversized
ego he was the great man the discoverer
of the whole of the pacific and everyone
should listen to what he had to say the
hawaiians were unimpressed by cook and
his men at this point and two days after
the ship's return to the bay one of the
resolution's longboats was stolen by the
hawaiians to get the boat back cook
decided on an old standby he would
kidnap the most important chief of the
island and hold him for ransom the next
day the 14th february 1779 cook put his
plan into action he rode ashore with the
ship's detachment of raw marines in tow
and set out for the chief's hut the
chief was still asleep when he was
awakened by cook and politely asked to
accompany him back to his ship believing
that he was being asked to visit the
ship as a guest the chief complied one
of his wives however realized something
was wrong and followed the party to the
beach wailing for help this alerted
other chiefs to the trouble who came to
the scene with their warriors by the
time cook and his men reached the beach
they were being followed by hundreds of
increasingly angry hawaiians the
captured chief suddenly realized that he
was being kidnapped and refused to get
into the row boat sitting down in the
sand instead cook's attempt to manhandle
the chief only made the crowd more angry
at this point cook should have realized
that he was outnumbered and let the
chief go discretion being the better
part of valor the cook was so used to
getting his way with the natives he'd
encountered on his adventures that he
made the fatal decision to persist with
his intimidation tactics no one is
exactly sure what started the fight
there are multiple accounts from
different people what is known is that a
general melee broke out in which four
royal marines and at least a dozen
hawaiians were killed at the center of
it all was james cook the famous sea
captain was knocked at the ground and
then stabbed in the chest with a metal
dagger ironically given to the hawaiians
as gift weeks earlier as the remaining
marines fled for their lives and the two
ships started firing on the crowd with
their cannons the hawaiians took turns
stabbing cook's body over and over again
they passed the dagger from one person
to another each getting a turn to plunge
it into his flesh cook was dead long
before they finally ceased
cook's body was dragged off the beach
and placed in a roasting pit until his
flesh had been cooked off his bones they
were pulled out and buried in secret
caves all over the islands four of the
most powerful chiefs ate cook's heart to
absorb his manner his power the only
bits of the captain's body recovered by
the crew of the resolution were his
hands and part of his skull which were
buried at sea the expedition carried on
undercooked subordinates and made
another attempt to find the northwest
passage but again they were foiled by
the ice pack blocking the way the two
ships slowly made their way back home
reaching britain in october 1780. by
then news of the death of cook had
already reached london and all of europe
was shocked by the dramatic death of the
world's most famous explorer cook's
posthumously published journals were a
literary sensation and captain cook
remains a cultural touchstone even in
the 21st century as pirate captain james
hook from peter pan and starship
enterprise captain james kirk are both
named after him from historical
standpoint cook has a very mixed legacy
on the one hand he was a renowned
explorer who filled in great swaths of
the world map on the other his brutal
treatment of the native populations he
encountered served as a forewarning of
the kinds of barbarity that would come
from the eventual colonization of these
islands by europeans so i really hope
you found that video interesting if you
did please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]